[Music]
you'd record some of my favorite movies
ever by the way
bring it on I did direct bring it on yes
yeah I just bring that up every time I
talk to you
did you ever slide in a bring it on or
like yes man reference into one of the
mm movies I think if I I think I
resisted the temptation to put a
cheerleading joke in ant-man mm-hmm I
don't think III
I don't know in terms of being self
referential all right I don't know if
I'm comfortable with that
okay I think I would down with love
maybe I know that we did this is weird
and down with love came out in 2003
there's a shot where there's a newsstand
that um
sarah paulson and renee zellweger is
standing in front of and there's a row
of Marvel comics from 1962 on the
newsstand including an ant-man comic Wow
that's weird but it's true power like
weird and serendipitous is that yeah
it's a lot okay but you've resisted cuz
like the Russo brothers just go all-in
oh yeah yeah um before I before I move
on to the like the actual movie are
promoting I'm just gonna stick on bring
it on for one more second do it um I'm
such a Stan of the Taurus but they're so
there were somebody bring it on sequels
but none quite capture the original
would you ever do like a sequel with
Kirsten Dunst and Gabrielle Union it's
something that we've actually talked
about and I've talked about it with the
actors and with Jessica mending or who
wrote what was called cheer fever and
became bring it on
but the idea of could you do like a 20
year later thing to just pick up where
they are now and make it this
generational thing
it's something we've kind of talked
about over the years and never quite
honed in on it but if it were the right
thing and it dealt with everybody having
these weird midlife crises and stuff I
think that could be really interesting
right yeah babe want to revisit their
cheer days yeah maybe they have died you
know be interesting to see kind of you
know what's happened to those characters
I think they're probably a large portion
of the audience who might be bummed out
because they can't all have gone on to
good things right like I did
cheerleading back in the bay that was
like I remember my mom took me in like a
group of the girls on the squad to go
see bring it on in theaters and like I
definitely don't cheer anymore because
of that movie oh yeah
my god
[Music]